peut-être merci la parole est à monsieur
axel poniatowski merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse
également aux ministres de l'économie et
des finances monsieur de médis ma
question ce porte également sur la grèce
non pas pour savoir quelle est la
position de la france mais finalement
pour savoir combien tout cela nous
coûtera à nous comme vous dites car les
différences sommet de cette semaine
permettront peut-être à la grèce
d'éviter un défaut de paiement à brève
échéance
mais à quel prix depuis son entrée dans
la zone euro en 2001 la grèce vit bien
au dessus de ses moyens et surtout elle
vit à crédit
l'europe demande aujourd'hui au
gouvernement de monsieur tsipras de
prendre quelques mesures en matière de
tva et de retraité est de présenter un
budget en excédent primaire ans depuis
son arrivée au pouvoir
monsieur de sipera ce al'inverse creuse
tous les jours un peu plus ces déficits
publics en l'accompagnant d'un zeste de
provocation a juré qu'il se croit que
jamais l'europe ne lâchera l'un de ses
membres et pourtant les demandes
formulées par la zone euro sont bien
modestes
en réalité quand on sait que le mal
profond dont souffre la grèce et qu'elle
est incapable de collecter l'impôt et
que le sport national est le recours à
l'économie souterraine
monsieur 2010 qu'un pays décident de
tricher au sein de ses frontières
c'est son affaire mais lorsque ces
frontières sont les nôtres cela devient
insupportable et surtout qu'il revient
aux européens de régler toutes les
factures de jeu de la grèce qui plus est
s'il y en a qu aurait trouvé tout le
monde sait bien que le sujet de
l'endettement reste taboue et que les
320 milliards de dettes cumulées depuis
15 ans ne seront jamais remboursés
d'ailleurs 110 milliards ont déjà été
passées par parayre pertes et profits je
relève en doute les propos stupéfiants
du premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste votre parti qui en début de
semaine appelé solennellement le fmi la
bce la commission à je cite cesser
d'entraver tout compromis en fait
d'entraver tout compromis nous sommes au
contraire dans la fuite en avant
monsieur le ministre ma question et
pierre seignat ça va coûter à la france
l'état monsieur michel sapin un ministre
des finances et des comptes publics
monsieur le député monsieur président
axel poniatowski je suis de ceux qui
considèrent je pense que vous en faites
partie aussi qu'il faut être exigeant
vis-à-vis de la majorité actuelle du
parlement grec dans le respect de la
démocratie dans le respect de la
démocratie
car s'il ya une nouvelle majorité s'il
ya un nouveau gouvernement en grèce ça
n'est pas pour faire exactement est en
tout point ce que faisait la présente
précédente majorité où le précédent
gouvernement sinon je ne comprends rien
à la démocratie ni là ni ailleurs il
faut être exigeant mais il faut être
juste
je vous ai trouvé un juste monsieur
bennett au ski c'est injuste de dire que
la situation actuelle en particulier du
point de vue des impôts ce que vous avez
décrit est juste serait de la
responsabilité de ce gouvernement
s'il ya un grave échec une grave
responsabilité de la part des
gouvernements précédents et des
majorités précédentes c'est de n'avoir
jamais apporté une réponse à ce que
demandait par ailleurs les institutions
comme on dit où les européens mettre en
place un système de perception de
l'impôt qui permette que tout le monde
paye l'impôt et surtout les plus riches
des grecs qui aujourd'hui s'exonère de
toute capacité à la sarre à verser à la
peau ça c'est la justice aussi et ce
gouvernement grec et nous le soutenons
veut qu'il y ait aussi de la justice
fiscale
là comme ailleurs c'est un des éléments
fondamentaux pour retrouver de la
stabilité pour faire en sorte qu'un
accord par ailleurs nécessaire qui doit
être exigeant juste et exigeant permette
à la grèce de retrouver quoi la
croissance nécessaire la croissance
l'emploi parce que ce pays monsieur
poniatowski depuis cinq ans cinq années
consécutives n'a pas cessé de baisser
baisser baisser perdent la richesse père
de l'activité perte de l'activité
et ça c'est pas la responsabilité du
gouvernement d'aujourd'hui donc soyons
exigeants mais soyons justes c'est comme
ça qu'on aboutir à un accord
merci